Today we're going to explore something called the preexisting duty rule by
looking at a case called Alaska packers association versus Dark Medico,
which was decided by the ninth circuit in 1902,
the Alaska Packers Association hired a group of sailors and salmon fishing
people,
including the named Appellee Dominico for a fishing expedition.
Alaska packers contracted to pay each of the workers $50 or $60 for the season.
But after the expedition began,
the workers stopped work and demanded a pay increase to $100 for the season
because the location was remote and the season was shored.
Alaska Packers Superintendent was unable to obtain replacement workers and so
conceited to the demands.
Uh,
when the work was completed and the workers returned from the expedition,
Alaska packers refused to honor the contractual modification and the worker sued
the trial court found for the plaintiff workers and the instant court reversed.
So the central issue is this,
was the contractual modification supported by consideration.
The ninth circuit held that the contractual modification lacked consideration.
The court observed that the workers agreed in writing for certain stated
compensation to render their services to the appellant in remote waters where
the season for conducting fishing operations is extremely short and and which,
and in which enterprise the appellant has a large amount of money invested.
In fact,
it was $150,000 invested in 1900.
Uh,
that was a lot of money.
The workers then waited until it was impossible for the appellant to secure
other men in their places and without any valid cause.
Absolutely refuse to continue the services they were under contract to perform
unless the appellant would consent to pay them more money.
The court concluded that Alaska packers consent to the workers' demands was a
without consideration for the reason that it was based solely upon the libel
it's agreement to render the exact services and none other that they were
already under contract to render.
By the way,
the plaintiffs are called liable.
It's because this is an admiralty case.
This is an example of what is known today as the preexisting duty rule.
The preexisting duty rule says that a preexisting duty cannot be used as
consideration for a contractual modification under the preexisting duty rule.
You can't promise not to kill the president for $1,000 because you already have
a duty not to kill the president as applied to contractual modifications.
The preexisting duty rule says that modifications to a contract unsupported by
additional consideration are unenforceable.
In other words,
if a party promised this to do something that is already legally bound to do,
his promise will not count as consideration to support a new contract with the
higher price.
The law will regard the promise as a new pactum,
a naked promise,
unclothed in consideration.
So here's a pop quiz.
Consideration is normally regarded as something which is bargained for and given
an exchange for a promise.
Was the additional pay bargain for?
Well,
the answer is yes.
This standard bargain requirement appears to have been satisfied in Alaska
packers.
The promise to increase the fishermen's wages was knocked gratuitous,
but was given to induce the Fisher men to complete their jobs.
Why then does the court reject the fishermen's position?
Well,
there's still this preexisting duty problem.
The fishermen already had a legal duty to perform the work.
So in legal effect,
they gave up nothing extra in return.
Threatening to withhold what you already had a legal duty to perform is not
consideration with the con.
With this question of consideration aside the court in Alaska packers,
it's also clearly concerned about the apparent duress exerted by the fishermen.
This was a holdup.
Extortion.
The fishermen seem to be saying to the defendants,
without justification,
unless you pay us more money to do the same work,
we will quit and leave you stuck in a remote Alaskan Bay without a paddle.
The court did not look kindly on the fishermen's gamesmanship,
citing and old Minnesota case called King versus railway company.
The court wrote that quote,
the party who refuses to perform and thereby coerces a promise from the other
party to the contract to pay him and increasing an increased compensation for
doing that which is legally bound to do,
takes an unjustifiable advantage of the necessity of that other party allowing
victims of a shakedown to enter into new but void contracts where uh,
they promise to make nonbinding promises to pay extra money might empower the
promises to fend off the shakedowns the immutable rule that modification must be
supported by consideration.
Thus might protect these potential victims.
The law does not allow them to be fleeced and,
and thereby might improve their bargaining strategy.
After this case.
Alaska packers can say,
I'd really like to promise to pay you more,
but that won't be a legally binding promise.
The preexisting duty rule is captured in section 73 of the restatement,
which reads performance of a legal duty owed to a promissory,
which is neither doubtful nor the subject of honest dispute is not
consideration,
but a similar performance is consideration if it differs from what was required
by the duty in a way which reflects more than a pretense of bargaining.
Note that the restatement definition allows for contractual modifications that
settle honest legal disputes or reflect more than just a pretense of bargaining.
This is not inconsistent with the opinion in Alaska packers,
which emphasize that the workers refuse to continue services without any valid
cause.
Well,
what would be a valid cause?
What if plaintiffs had claimed that defendant Alaska,
uh,
was somehow in breach of its duty to provide decent dormitories and the extra
money was compensation for defendant's breach of the implicit promise to provide
livable working conditions.
Or suppose that severe weather increased the risks of harm to the fishers,
or what if Alaska packers provided the fishermen with inferior nets?
This last point is more than just a hypothetical.
In Alaska packers,
the fishermen tried to prove that the nets furnished to them.
We're not serviceable because they permitted smaller salmon to slip through in
her law review article,
a fish story,
Alaska packers versus Dominica.
Debra 3-d suggests that the fishermen,
because of differences in language and experience might have misunderstood that
the nets were serviceable.
While this would not justify a strike,
it tends to neutralize the claim of duress.
3D also suggests that nets which appear on serviceable to those hoping to catch
more fish would be perfect for the packers who were concerned about catching too
many fish or perhaps wanted to cut corners on the equipment.
So let's turn now to the uh,
uh,
the problem of the dissatisfied entertainer.
Imagine that you are a justice of a state appellate court hearing and appeal
from a judgment entered in the circuit court after a jury trial in which the
plaintiff,
Oliver Ajax,
received a verdict of $30,000 in a breach of contract action against the
defendant James Bond.
On February 15th.
A Jack and bond entered into a written contract whereby Ajax,
a professional entertainer,
was to perform at bond's resort for the week of July 1st through July 7th for a
fee of $20,000.
In the late spring,
Ajax had a hit record,
which virtually overnight made him a star who could command at least a $50,000
fee for a one week engagement.
In early June,
Ajax contacted bond to renegotiate their contract,
demanding $50,000 for this one week,
uh,
engagement initially bond refuse to renegotiate.
But when a Jack said that he would not perform,
bond relented after discussion.
Bond dictated a new contract to a stenographer and the exact words of the
original contract and running for the same period.
But with the compensation change to $50,000.
As they signed the new contract,
they tore up the old one.
Thereafter,
Ajax kept the engagement,
but bond refused to pay him more than $20,000.
A Jack's filed the instant suit,
uh,
seeking the additional $30,000 over the defendant's objection.
The trial judge instructed the jury as follows,
quote,
if you find that the $20,000 contract was prior to,
or at the time of the execution of the $50,000 contract canceled and revoked by
the parties by their mutual consent,
then it is your duty.
Find that there was consideration for the making of the contract in this suit.
And in that event,
the plaintiff is entitled to your verdict in the amount of $30,000 unquote on
this appeal.
The defendant contends that giving,
that the giving of this instruction constituted a reversible error.
So what should be done,
this case is,
and another example of consideration being really a matter of form.
If you can convince a court that is a formality,
you tore up the first contract first and then replaced it with a second modified
contract that really is convincing the court,
uh,
in a purely formal manner to give rise to a con,
a modified contract with no consideration.
But the idea of,
of consideration is merely being a formality is one that was actually championed
by Lon fuller who said that mere formalities can produce,
um,
functional goods.
A fuller,
uh,
taught us that consideration as form might provide value,
because it provides one an evidentiary function of providing evidence to courts
that the parties intended to contract.
It also provides a cautionary,
um,
a goal of a cautionary function.
That formalities might slow people down to make that they only enter into
contracts that they want to be legally enforceable.
And finally,
formalities including consideration is merely a formality,
might serve a channeling function of channeling people toward contracts that,
um,
uh,
that they really want to be legally enforceable and channeling other kinds of
agreements to nonlegal enforcement.
Now and while this is a positive view of consideration is form,
there's another image of consideration is formed that's not as happy.
It's a more cynical view that a consideration is a mere formality.
That is a trap,
uh,
for people who just don't know how to manipulate it or it's a way of generating
income for lawyers.
You better go get a lawyer if you want to make sure that your contract is
enforced because the lawyer will know enough to dress it up with the trappings
of consideration.
May Be having the singer in the Ajax case sing an extra song or throw in a meet
and greet with fans.
Let's move on to another case.
This is the case of the subcontractors added inducement.
Edward Woodward in this is the owner of a large smelting operation in
metropolis.
On August 7th Woodward entered into a written contract with Peter Rogers,
a general contractor for the construction of an additional power plant at his
place of business.
On August 14th Rogers entered into a written subcontract with John Newman for
the erection of structural steelwork required for this new power plant and for
the purpose of performing his work.
Newman rented certain equipment for use until the job was completed.
The work continued until October 7th when the strike occurred among Newman's
employees and the work was gets discontinued for a period of approximately nine
weeks.
During this time,
Newman,
the subcontractor was obliged to pay rent for the equipment and other sums to
ensure it's safe.
Keeping a meeting was called to adjust differences in the contract in attendance
were Newman,
the subcontractor,
Rogers,
the general contractor,
and Woodward,
the ultimate client and a representative of the Union of the strikers.
As a result of the lengthy discussion,
the strike was called off.
However,
Doman refuse to continue performance unless he was paid for the rental and
charges accruing during the time of the strike.
Woodward then promised to pay this extra amount so that the work could proceed.
The work was completed under the contracts,
but Woodward then refuse to pay the rental charges that he had promised in the
modification.
And Newman consults you for,
uh,
for advice on whether a Newman can enforce the promise from Woodward to pay for
the rental charges.
So this problem presents us with a situation where additional consideration is
paid,
but not by the other side of the contract.
Newman's has a preexisting duty to the general contractor,
Rogers,
but not to the underlying client.
Woodward.
So Woodward,
a third party to the Rogers Newman contract is pain for something that Newman
already owes,
but not to Woodward.
What's the result?
Well,
there's a trend in the cases to treat the three party situation differently,
uh,
for at least three reasons.
First,
with a third party,
there may be a smaller likelihood of duress.
And second,
the promise.
See here,
Newman doesn't have a preexisting duty to the third party Woodward,
even following the strictness of the preexisting duty rule,
one can find the additional peppercorn in the promises for bearing to affect
rescission with regard to the third party.
And finally,
third,
the third party may be under compensated by contractual damages and therefore
the modification may promote efficiency.
In this case,
one could buttress a result favoring enforcement of the um,
modify modification without consideration by drawing upon an unforeseen
difficulty exception that although developed in the two party context would seem
to apply in the three party settling as well.
Note,
however,
that the promise he may have caused the strike here.
So let's review.
Today we've learned that modifications to a contract or unenforceable if there
aren't supported by additional consideration.
This is known as the preexisting duty rule.